good morning doctor morning two kids towards
three another game sites are in the South siders
ten police had like a full report they called me
about it seems to be a lot of these fights lately
another gang fight two kids hurt Peters
and wits 18 stab wound and Laura Gilman
right fracture of the radius no
infection condition satisfactory
Thomas Kean fractured ribs lower left
perforated lung left no infection
condition satisfactory the laboratory
found no infection nothing that showed
up under a microscope or in a test tube
nothing you could fight with a drug or
serum condition satisfactory I doubted it
the two boys mind if I talk with him talk
are you feeling okay my name is Nora doll you
know what a psychiatrist is again I see movies
tell me why did you and your friends attack
the other crowd you kiddin they started it
and we're gonna finish it we're gonna settle
with those punks wait a minute the police
report says that you and your friends went to
Peters and whit's house and started the fight
Peters in with oh I see then we didn't start
the fight faded everyone makes mistakes I made
the common mistake of judging by appearances
everyone even a psychiatrist make snap judgments
sometimes often it's final judgment passing
sentence for a crime that was never committed
but if you got against Peters and wits he's like
all the rest of them risk the rest of plot Pollock
always Horning in with an unwanted yr7 to come
over here anyway who do they think they are who
do you think they are Tom Pollock dirty stinking
[ __ ] the old familiar hate words here is dirty
stinking pollux other places it's dirty degos mix
breezers [ __ ] chinks sniggers how does hate like
this begin to pile up where does it start what do
you do about it that's what the police wanted to
know that's what I was supposed to tell them first
of all I had to get the whole story I called in a
caseworker Jeff Holland Jeff was experienced
at this kind of thing how does the hate begin
to pile up where does it start Jeff would try to
find the answers he went down to the south side to
the Polish section an American section actually in
which many of the residents are of Polish ancestry
their parents and grandparents came from a poor
country wanting a better life willing to work
for it some mutter done pretty well in struggle
different customs different backgrounds but the
same human needs and wants above all the desire to
belong not to be an outsider which is sometimes a
struggle in itself it's hard to understand why you
have to get kicked around for having a different
sounding name for speaking with a different accent
you want to know how it happened well I ask you
how it happens why those kids make trouble for us
don't you run the police what do they do why don't
they stop it did he come to only to ask us right
we are trying to stop it but I've got to have your
help these things just don't happen there's always
a reason for it tell me do you know the Gregory's
oh I know they're more right rota tattoos bunchy
horse what Papa means we don't really know them we
know only about them they don't come how should
I say bother with our neighborhood it's hard to
explain there are some people just we just learned
a little through the venlet's family he hoped to
learn more from the Gregory just a few blocks away
from the Polish section a modest house on a street
in modest houses but countless other houses on
countless other streets a neighborhood of people
go to church read the newspapers listen to the
radio of their friend in Mallen band people who
lead a quiet orderly life they're taking good
care of him there's nothing you need he will be
all right woody I mean you'll get well all right
you'll be all right don't worry but I must know
more about what happened Oh for the life of me
I I just don't know we can't figure it out it's
terrible I hate to think what the neighbors must
be saying was there bad feeling between the two
boys not as far as I know of course tom is quiet
he doesn't say much no that's because I've always
made him toward the line the way I was brought up
and well that's the way we've tried to raise Tom
you know just then to see the Zen Woodsen can't
pay much attention to what they say you know what
they're like what do you mean what they're like
they're pull-ups oh now I'm not trying to excuse
Tom but because they can be silly no better no
worse no mother you don't even know them you've
never let yourself know them I do Peter's a friend
of mine they're not our time there are different
sort of people entirely is that fair my hair is
longer than yours should I cut it off that will
be enough out of you young lady what are they
wild a little bit from Sonora you heard your
father Laura has heard her father for many years
but Laura it seems has learned to do her own
thinking she has her own ideas she has confidence
in herself and what she believes she doesn't need
to step all over people in order to build herself
up Harold Gregory does have just found out like
everyone he wants to get ahead have people look
up to him he always wanted praise even as a child
instead he got discipline and punishment in his
job and then still others always seem to get the
prizes he wants 15 years of the same desk the
bookkeeper for a steel company quiet unobtrusive
fairly competent a few small raises but no
promotions five favoritism dirty politics yl so
the products moving in and moving up Gregory has
his own answer it's because they are so aggressive
because they're so tricky and unscrupulous some
of them down at the mill make almost as much as
he does how come fine way to treat an American if
at first you don't succeed blame somebody else the
palak's the hankies the foreigners they're stupid
and dirty but they are smart and tricky they're
lazy but they're too ambitious there anything
he wants them to be a handy target for his own
feeling of inadequacy he could work harder but
it's easier to find a scapegoat he could accept
his limitations and try to live with it but it's
easier to shift the blame mrs. Gregory considers
herself a conscientious mother I've I've tried
to bring my family up properly to see that they
have a good home nicely and associated with nice
children I don't know what Thomas no problem good
right nice proper a jet was to find out they added
up to something else fear of not being good enough
fear that she would always stay in the same room
but she would never climb the social ladder there
are many who have the same fear joined together
they have strength of a cane there is always
someone more vulnerable ok believe me I have a
personal feeling but background we just don't see
things the way we doing we don't want to lower
our standard she doesn't know why tom has been
such a problem it was a gradual process no child
is born prejudiced children have to be taught how
to hate whom to hate she raised Tom carefully
she knew about smallpox and other infectious
diseases she had him immunized she didn't know
that she herself could infect him thinking all
the while she was doing the right thing well
they do have wonderful bargain yes I suppose
they do that's the way they take things away from
our own people the old if their prices are lower
well I don't mean to tell you your business [ __
] after all if you want to shop here that's up
for you personally I don't think it's right after
all the polls is a plantation not trustworthy and
we really have to think of our own people what
the infection was slow to take hold Tom couldn't
see anything wrong or the kids in the Polish
section he didn't notice that they were different
you do as you're told understand stay
away from those products they no good
no good way no good never mind why don't ask
questions do as you're told the little man
at the office becomes the begging hammer
form the voice of authority a fluorescing
wielded a thousand times darkening
the years that should be filled with
sunshine only becomes a place of rules and
regulations subliminal and not enough love
without my knife
I rather play
it takes time but the pattern develops no
chance to work off his aggressions normally
he finds other ways ways to get even with
parents who hold too tight arraigned on him
a problem child at the age of eleven sulky furtive
hemmed in unsure of himself running off sometimes
to play with the poles wanting to feel superior
to somebody kids like Pete then wits Anton Miller
cough ski real cubic Stan little of names but
they can shoot a BB gun alright well you can't
I'm better than the dumb
poleaxe every day in the week 22
would you like maybe on yogi
strange food strange ways strange people different
for them he senses hidden things mysteries
a different kind of church where they speak a
strange language Latin strange different therefore
dangerous I can't find my best gift tonight have
either of you children's penis mm-hmm not me you
know what Pete sandwich has got a brand-new BB
gun I mean Peter what are you doing over there
walking by the old cubics got a bike welcome I
can't have one daddy can't afford it dummy I'll
decide what I can afford where did the poor
not get all their money not nice to call on
[ __ ] maybe I can get your own bike next year
next year that's enough are you gonna keep quiet
tom was learning to hate and not just at home
there were others who contributes advance share
there was Miss Bernette never really interested
in teaching frustrated unloved resenting her
drab life and taking it out on the kid what
do you mean disrupting the plan if you hope
to amount to anything you'll drop those tips
let's polish habits and attend to business
do you understand that do you understand
me Peter's enemy yes yes what yes ma'am
so gangs devote insiders against outsiders
the outsiders have been beaten but once
isn't enough you have to go on improving
yourself out of fear and frustration the
hate grows out of insecurity the need
to be powerful the master the Conqueror
the kids Karthus fooling around well
why not there's nothing mother with
breakfast too old for this kids stuff
Tom no I don't want any more of it
around why does everyone have to do things the
same way that's the trouble with you there's a
quite strong way to do everything Laura Laura
gets away with it she is rebellious but her
rebellion doesn't really count in the Gregory
world it's the man's opinion with method Laura
not having it that way she is set a course
her own course and she intends to follow it
she studies hard does her own thinking there is
room in her mind for as many opinions as there
are different kinds of people no one is going
to tell her how to choose her own friend Oh
my way that I'm going doing good
do you think you can carry me if she likes a boy
she likes him whether his name is John Jones or
Peters endlich's but to those whose minds are
surrounded by high walls differences are wrong
dangerous they hate whatever is different
and the hatred Wells wound together they
tell themselves it's masculine to hate hey
Laura's getting up in the world hobnobbing
with Pete Stanley she gets along just fine with
those Pollock I watch the secret of her success
she's a soap I wonder if they get me where with
it how about it Tom give us the lowdown nah
shut your mouth or I'll shut it for you
now once more I'm gonna ask you how long
have you been playing around with Devlin
I'm not playing around with it how many times
do I have to Peters having a party tonight he
asked me to come that's all darling there
are lots of a nice book well what's wrong
with Peters beautiful art he's a [ __ ]
that settles everything as far as you're
concerned that's not wanting sister of mine
running around it's good as you are now run
better what's on what you're saying young
lady I don't want to hear any more about
it going calling up and telling you're
not going and that's final what final
I told her off all right don't the
old man you won't be playing around
with that [ __ ] anymore hey I got news
they're having a party over Pete's in
with big deal they don't look at that cake
yeah you like having some fun right what
do you say we crash [ __ ] everybody they
might get sore what's the matter chicken
chicken I'll crash any party I want
now you're one of us let's go boys
pick up those things about a
hole got everything let's go
again guys on the south side the sort of eruption
might happen almost anywhere when the pressure of
hate becomes strong enough I knew now where it
began in the home with the parents and probably
with their parents before then we knew the source
and how it developed but they remained another
of your question to be answered how to cure it
not just here but everywhere or prejudice is a
disease a communicable disease it shows up in many
places takes many forms if few of us recognize the
symptoms in ourselves often it requires testing
himself like testing our eyesight is my vision
distorted do certain names frighten or anger me
certain colors faces accents certain religions
if so then I to an infected a menace to everyone
around me my own worst enemy for make no mistake
about it prejudice is a crippling disease
but no one is born with this disease no one
is born prejudice he has to be taught how to
hate pointing to hate it begins in the hole
transmitted from parent to child it's because it's
contagious it feeds on frustration and insecurity
on a feeling of social inferiority on the ported
need for love from stifled aggression hate and
violence prejudice can be cured by recognizing
it in ourselves fighting of how much wiser and
the easier to immunize against it from the
very big providing love and security for
the infant and the child a chance to let off
steam by making things and destroying them
if he wants not wholesale destruction but a
chance to get rid of aggression harmlessly
the chance to learn that we're not all alike
that being different in itself is not dangerous
putting everyone's talents to good use
playgrounds free to everyone decent sanitary
housing for every family an equal chance to
earn a living healthy competition a chance
to work off excess energy and hostility all
of these helped make us immune for prejudice
and finally by immunizing ourselves we no longer
fear smallpox hysteria and many other diseases why
not do the same with the disease of prejudice
this is our hope our real hope for the future